porque regresa esta escalada de
violencia y se produce justo en este
momento
de las situaciones que están
solapadas y que se mantienen latentes en
zonas de conflictos que la solución
digamos de raíz para llegar a tener un
espacio de paz y tranquilidad en una
zona que ya es la tercera vez que
tenemos en guerra pueda la potencias
poner de acuerdo más aún cuando las
mismas
potencias que hegemonizaron en la zona
como fue el caso de Rusia muy
específicamente
stalin en un territorio
habitado mayoritariamente por armenios
lo hizo formar parte de azerbaiyán
cuando formaban parte de la Unión de
repúblicas socialista soviéticas y luego
cuando llegue el periodo de la
Democracia o pegamos así después en la
caída de la URSS lo que aprovecha en en
este caso Armenia que es un país
cristiano hay que ver el elemento
cristiano
musulmán con los aseríes que son
musulmanes chiquitas enfrentados
frutos fruto de una situación que fue la
mala delimitación digamos así fronteriza
por parte de una potencia como es el
caso de Rusia que tiene firmado a su vez
un acuerdo con Armenia para protegerle
de cualquier ataque militar desde el
extranjero por eso vemos fuerzas
militares rusas que han servido de
garantía para mantener la paz pero esto
no ha sido posible entonces hay un
elemento adicional que debemos ver en
todo esto y es que azerbaiyán es un
pueblo Turco que tiene una un apoyo de
Turquía en este caso eso es un tema muy
complejo fruto de esas fronteras
delimitadas por los imperios bueno
justamente Pues en 2020 Rusia logró
mediar una especie de se hace al fuego
qué tan dañado está hoy el estatus del
kremlin como mediador tras haber
invadido Ucrania
Bueno aquí hay que hay que ver que por
ejemplo
los dos que pueden llevar la situación a
un nivel de solución son Turquía y Rusia
y hemos visto las buenas migas las
relaciones digamos así próximas tanto
entre Rusia como como Turquía que serían
los dos es fundamentales para ayudar a
solucionar la situación de hecho vemos
incluso a una Turquía que es miembro de
la otan que apoya a azerbaiyán y un
Europa que de una manera u otra cierta
siente cierta inclinación por hacer
vayan por la gran cantidad de gas que
poseen y que ante la situación de
emergencia que tienen por el tema del
gas los europeos parece que su
inclinación podría ser por hacer vayan
del otro lado Armenia es un país que es
el primer país cristiano de la historia
entonces hay una gran migración de de
armenio de armenios tanto en en Francia
como en Estados Unidos en muchos países
de América Latina y todo esto hace un
poco complejo el problema pero los dos
que pueden decidir el problema Son
Turquía y Rusia Aunque vimos las
declaraciones de Anthony blinking el
secretario de estado de los Estados
Unidos quien llamaba a una solución
pacífica y que la solución de este
problema no puedes militar bueno y los
choques justamente podrían llegar a esta
escala que vimos en 2020 podría
producirse esta que Se involucra en
potencias como Rusia o Turquía como
usted lo estaba mencionando
digamos que de manera directa muy
difícil lleguen a hacerlo aquí lo que se
ha ido viendo Es que la la táctica que
han tenido o digamos la estrategia
llevando a cabo tácticas de ir logrando
que la población Armenia que está en esa
zona de nagorno canabaj que es de más de
4000 kilómetros cuadrados dada la
destrucción que se sucede en cada Guerra
y la amenaza de una futura guerra la
población Armenia vaya
aislándose oyéndose de la zona de
conflicto y dejando el espacio para los